[Musica]
immaginate di essere un cittadino
americano e venire a conoscenza di un
mandato di arresto nei vostri confronti
fino a qui niente di eccessivamente
strano sapete di essere innocenti e
anche se non conoscete il motivo del
resto avete la coscienza a posto
vi recate alla stazione di polizia per
chiarire la situazione e contestualmente
venite ammanettati senza nessuna
spiegazione
ecco già questo è più preoccupante
passano le ore e a un certo punto mi
viene mostrata la foto di una patente e
gli agenti vi dicono sappiamo cosa hai
fatto
poi guardate la foto però e non potete
fare a meno di notare che si tratti di
un'altra persona quindi vite non vedete
che non sono io
l'unica cosa che ho in comune con questa
persona sono il colore della pelle e la
barba ciononostante nager parks ha
passato dieci giorni in prigione in
attesa dell'udienza il procuratore gli
ha offerto nel frattempo un accordo
una confessione per un reato che non ha
mai commesso
in cambio di sei anni in prigione e tre
anni in libertà vigilata dopo il suo
rilascio
andando processo ne avrebbe rischiati 25
ci ha pensato molto perché sa come vanno
queste cose ma alla fine sapendo di
essere innocente ha deciso di spendere
tutti i suoi risparmi e pagare un
avvocato
successivamente con le indagini si è
scoperto che parks era stato indicato
come sospetto non da un pubblico
ministero
ma è un software di riconoscimento
facciale che aveva individuato una
correlazione tra la foto della patente
che gli era stata mostrata e il suo
volto si è scoperto anche che era stato
detenuto per dieci giorni perché il new
jersey non prevede un sistema di
cauzione ma utilizza invece un algoritmo
che valuta rischio dell'indagato per
determinare se può essere rilasciato
prima del processo
parks che da giovane era stato
condannato
per due reati minori era a rischio in
soli due giorni
parks stato soggetto a due diversi
processi automatizzati che hanno deciso
per la sua vita
il primo quello che la erroneamente
identificato il secondo che ha deciso
che doveva rimanere in carcere
grazie ad altri casi simili di ingiusti
arresti a causa di errori di
riconoscimento facciale negli ultimi
anni
sappiamo che ad esempio il sistema che
utilizzava la polizia di detroit aveva
un tasso di errore del 90 per cento ma
veniva comunque utilizzato nel 2018 due
ricercatrici vola minime che ha blu
hanno scoperto per la prima volta che i
sistemi di riconoscimento facciale
venduti da amazon
ibm e microsoft non riuscivano a
riconoscere tutti i volti allo stesso
modo e che le donne in cor di colore in
particolare non venivano riconosciute
nel 34 per cento dei casi lo studi
mostrava anche come in generale le
percentuali di errore fossero più alte
se le tecnologie venivano utilizzate su
persone nere orari pensate a cosa è
successo a parkes
ma cosa è cambiato da allora e qual è la
situazione oggi la consapevolezza sul
tema dei buyout così vengono definiti vi
errori algoritmici è sicuramente
cresciuta ed è probabile che molti tra
voi ne abbiano già sentito parlare
almeno una volta
questo perché essendo cresciuto
ampiamente negli ultimi anni il campo
dell'intelligenza artificiale e gli
investimenti è cresciuto anche il
dibattito sui potenziali errori e rischi
di buyers e questo è già un passo in
avanti nel frattempo il new jersey come
altri stati americani ha posto una
moratoria nei sistemi di riconoscimento
facciale utilizzati dalla polizia in
europa anche da noi se è stato previsto
negli ultimi anni l'utilizzo di questi
sistemi ad esempio in francia in grecia
e anche in italia senza nessun successo
per fortuna questo lo aggiungo io
per molte persone invece riconoscimento
biometrico o quella direttore delle
emozioni potrebbe essere una grande
opportunità economica una tecnologia che
si ripromette di cogliere le nostre
emozioni dal nostro sguardo o movimenti
della nostra faccia o il nostro genere
dai nostri lineamenti pensate quanti
benefici per alcuni settori si tratta
però solo di un esempio
in realtà sono molti altri gli esempi di
processi decisionali automatizzati usati
nei nostri paesi ad esempio per
digitalizzare il welfare o per
automatizzare i compiti delle pubbliche
amministrazioni a gennaio nei paesi
bassi è scoppiato uno scandalo dopo che
è emerso come negli ultimi dieci anni 26
in fila famiglie fossero state accusate
ingiustamente di frode ai sussidi
sociali ricevuti per la cura e la
crescita dei figli
tutte famiglie a cui nel corso degli
anni è stato chiesto di ridare del
denaro alle autorità fiscali
ora immaginate di essere una cittadina
olandese ha qui da un giorno all'altro
viene richiesto di restituire 30 mila
euro alle autorità
ovviamente molte famiglie sono andate in
bancarotta
alcune hanno perso il lavoro la casa
addirittura la famiglia e i figli
ecco quest'anno si è scoperto che un
processo automatizzato aveva fatto male
i conti e che usava come indicatori
delle variabili dei proxy discriminatori
come la doppia cittadinanza per
segnalare automaticamente un rischio di
frode questo è l'esempio di una
democrazia europea che quando
digitalizzata può diventare un po meno
giusta perché i cittadini olandesi non è
stata data la possibilità di contestare
quelle decisioni come non gli è stata
data la possibilità di visionare la
documentazione che ha portato a quelle
decisioni
questo perché quando automatizzate si
perde molta comprensione di queste
pratiche e anche un po di responsabilità
non sarebbe potuto succedere anche a me
perché le persone che il sistema aveva
accusato avevano un background
migratorio come ad esempio una
cittadinanza turca
l'algoritmo ha quindi amplificato e
delle discriminazioni che esistevano già
da sempre quello che potrebbe succedere
a me però è di candidarmi per un posto
di lavoro e scoprire di essere
automaticamente rigettata da un software
senza nemmeno analizzare le mie
competenze per il mio genere o vedermi
rigettato un prestito perché le donne
hanno meno affidabilità creditizia
rispetto agli uomini
il primo ricordo della parola algoritmo
risale al liceo ero stata chiamata
interrogata la lavagna e il professore
dell'epoca davanti al mio evidente
blocco mi disse di latta guarda che
poteva andarci peggio
pensa se devi studiare gli algoritmi
io poi non c'è più pensato ho iniziato
la facoltà di filosofia studiavo tra gli
altri il razionalismo il positivismo con
uno sguardo critico non mi convincevano
la fiducia incondizionata nel progresso
tecnologico e scientifico al di sopra di
ogni cosa e la contrapposizione netta
tra scienza e vaghezza reale e illusione
pian piano ho iniziato a capire cosa mi
piaceva e passando per la filosofia
femminista una teoria in particolare
quella del cyborg né illuminata una
metafora prese dal mondo scientifico e
tecnologico per rappresentare un ibrido
in grado finalmente di superare tutte
quelle categorie quei due ali smi
perfetti a cui siamo sempre stati
abituati uomo donna omosessuale
eterosessuale uomo animale bianco nero
categorie che per moltissimo tempo sono
state viste come contrapposte e
inconciliabili e che rispecchiano il
funzionamento proprio delle macchine gli
studi sul genere e la tecnologia e
l'etica mi hanno insegnato che ogni
tecnologia è necessariamente politica
che non c'è un solo modo di interpretare
cosa razionale ma che ne esiste uno per
almeno ognuno di noi che esistono le
sfumature e infinite differenti
ma che dobbiamo per forza insegnarlo noi
alle macchine non è stato e siamo
abituati a pensarlo come un processo
neutro e autonomo quello tecnologico è
necessariamente un processo creativo
fatto di scelte e decisioni umane scelte
che sono per forza condizionate dal
contesto di riferimento
il fatto che ad esempio in europa siano
solo il 17 per cento le donne ai vertici
del settore ai siti non è un caso è
qualcosa che influisce inevitabilmente
sulla costruzione sociale della
tecnologia
io poi un po gli algoritmi li ho
studiati e quando ho capito che i dati
raccontano delle nostre storie
ho iniziato avere un po meno paura
il distacco iniziale era data dal fatto
che non riuscivo a capire come la
matematica e gli algoritmi potessero
riflettere i nostri valori
in realtà lo fanno eccome per raccontare
che raccontano le nostre esperienze e i
nostri pregiudizi ma se è vero che i by
us nei dati non sono del tutto
inevitabili dato che appunto i dati
raccontano i nostri pregiudizi non c'è
nulla di inevitabile nel programmare un
sistema che non funziona su alcune
persone per questo è importante pensare
criticamente e riprenderci un po della
nostra responsabilità chiederci quando
progettiamo un software più o meno
intelligente per chi lo stiamo
progettando e su chi deve funzionare
stiamo tenendo in considerazioni tutte
le variabili e conseguenze negative
prevedibili ci serve davvero una
tecnologia per automatizzare questo
compito
da quando condivido le mie attività e
parlo di questi temi c'è una domanda in
particolare che mi viene rivolta molto
spesso magli se gli esseri umani hanno
gli stessi pregiudizi cosa dovrebbe
cambiare
torniamo all'inizio quando ha raccontato
del resto di parks e dei casi di frode
nei paesi bassi
entrambe decisioni che hanno avuto un
impatto enorme per prima cosa noi esseri
umani abbiamo delle capacità
fondamentali
macchine non hanno una di questa è
quella di saper contestualizzare
ricevere feedback e fare analisi di
conseguenza sono sicuri infatti che non
tutti tra noi avrebbero necessariamente
associata una doppia cittadinanza a un
rischio di frode le decisioni
automatizzate poi agiscono su enorme
scala e possono essere applicate nello
stesso istante a migliaia di persone
anche dall'altra parte del mondo perché
basta una sola caratteristica per
accomunarci a causa di queste
generalizzazioni le decisioni algoritmi
che hanno potenzialmente il potere di
cancellare anni di lotte e di diritti
perché non riescono a stare al passo con
la nostra storia conoscono solo ciò che
noi insegniamo loro senza sapere però
come ci siamo arrivati e con quanti anni
di battaglie sociali e non
necessariamente tutti tra noi
sceglierebbero di insegnare alle
macchine le stesse conquiste non deve
essere per forza così però come dicevo
prima la tecnologia è un nostro prodotto
e non è vero che essendo matematica non
possiamo fare nulla per cambiarla sono
molte le cose che si possono fare per
renderla una forza positiva possiamo
pretendere che alcuni suoi utilizzi ad
esempio come riconoscimento facciale o
quello delle emozioni vengono vietati o
pretendere che i software che vengono
usati su di noi e che ci giudicano
passino dei controlli ben precisi prima
di essere commercializzati possiamo
supportare le tante iniziative sui
diritti digitali portate avanti da
associazioni e organizzazioni
perché se vogliamo davvero contribuire a
un futuro digitale che sia giusto allora
dobbiamo essere tutti consapevoli di
questi processi sia per noi stessi e per
gli altri
dobbiamo pretendere l'estensione dei
nostri diritti per tutelare i nostri
dati e le nostre differenze perché anche
questo dipenderà il futuro delle nostre
democrazie